[Musique]
beaucoup sur cette oeuvre
sur ce cette aide de l'état puisque nous
avons dans notre projet beaucoup d'idées
pour améliorer vivre ensemble de
l'aqualud pour revitaliser le
centre-ville pour essayer de rénover nos
infrastructures existantes et rien n'est
précisé aujourd'hui d'après ce qu'on m'a
dit c'est que la première étape à être
dans ce bois de l'aide d'un directeur de
projet pour nous aider à faire un plan
de territoire quel premier projet c'est
ce que j'appelle un plan guide
l'idée c'est de nous associer à un
architecte assez connus qui s'appelle
alexandre chemetoff donc il nous a
proposé de nous aider pendant les
promenades reviennent à faire un travail
de réflexion de visualisation de notre
avenir à 15 ou 20 ans ça c'est un
élément essentiel
donc c'est un travail qui va nous
permettre mon équipe d'adjoints mon
équipe municipale et lui est bien de de
décliner les projets que nous aurons un
pronostic à réaliser dans ce mandat